HILARIOUS APOLOGY TO THE PEOPLE
OF CANADA.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY ONE THING.
[BLEEP] TRUMP.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A NOTE OF
APOLOGY FOR THE IDIOTIC BEHAVIOR
OF MY PRESIDENT AND I APOLOGIZE
TO JUSTIN TRUDEAU AND THE OTHER
PEOPLE AT THE G7.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> Tucker: A LOT OF PEOPLE GET
DEEPER AND MORE THOUGHTFUL AS
THEY GET OLDER.
NOT THE CASE WITH ROBERT DE NIRO
BUT HE'S GETTING SUPPORT FROM
HOLLYWOOD.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR AMERICAN
POLITICS?
DOES THE IMAGE OF RICH ACTORS
SWEARING AT THE PRESIDENT AT AN
ORANGE SHOW HELP THE PRESIDENT
OR HURT HIM?
JOE PISCOPO JOINS US FROM THE
STREETS OF THE METROPOLIS OF
8 MILLION.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU FROM THE
BRONX, NEW YORK.
OUR LADY OF MOUNT CARAMEL.
ST. ANTHONY FESTIVAL.
I'M GETTING MY BLESSINGS.
GOD BLESS YOU, MY SON.
OR WHAT EFFECT DOES THIS HAVE ON
NORMAL PEOPLE, DO YOU THINK?
WHO WEREN'T IN THE AUDIENCE OR
AREN'T "HUFFINGTON POST" CHARTER
SUBSCRIBERS.
HOW DO THEY REACT TO ROBERT
DE NIRO'S SPEECH?
HIS 2-WORD SPEECH?
>> FROM THE STREETS OF THE BRONX
HERE, A GREAT ITALIAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY, WE IDOLIZE ROBERT
DE NIRO.
GREAT RESPECT FOR THE BRILLIANCE
OF ROBERT DE NIRO BUT TO GO ON
LIVE TELEVISION.
HE'S FROM NEW YORK.
I'M TELLING YOU THIS WILL ENSURE
DONALD TRUMP'S ELECTION IN 2020.
TO BE THAT REPREHENSIBLE AND TO
BE THAT VULGAR ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
AGAIN, I HAVE IMMENSE RESPECT
FOR THIS MAN, BUT IT WILL
RESONATE WITH THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE, YOU
HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT FOR.
THE G7 SUMMIT WAS A NEGOTIATION.
THE PRESIDENT SAID --
IT'S A NEGOTIATION.
THEN HE SITS DOWN WITH
KIM JONG UN, IT'S MONUMENTAL.
IT'S EPIC, HISTORIC.
THE COUNTRIES EMBRACING IT, AND
NORTH KOREA IS EMBRACING IT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PEACE HERE,
AND TO GET ONE OF YOUR HEROES TO
BE THAT VULGAR ON LIVE
TELEVISION, TUCKER, IT DOESN'T
PLAY ACROSS THE REST OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: IT'S A WEIRD
RESPONSE.
ISN'T THE ARGUMENT AGAINST TRUMP
THAT HE'S VULGAR?
IT'S HARD TO MAKE THAT ARGUMENT
IF I AM SCREAMING F TRUMP AT AN
AWARDS SHOW.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF BOBBY
DE NIRO CAUGHT UP THERE AND SAID
I HEARD THINGS.
I HEARD SOME THINGS.
HE COULD HAVE FUN WITH IT.
ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
THE BRILLIANCE OF BROADWAY, THE
GREATEST ENTERTAINERS IN THE
WORLD ON THE GREAT WHITE WAY.
THE BRILLIANCE OF BROADWAY
TALENTS.
TO TAKE THAT SHOWED THAT LEVEL,
IT WAS VERY, VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
AND I AM BEING POLITE.
>> Tucker: ESPECIALLY SINCE HE
HAS MADE SO MANY GREAT MOVIES.